just looking at the different mechanisms
that made all of this happen so this is
not just one guy Stalin having a policy
there's a whole system
I mean one of it is just a system of
fear
but how do you implement that system of
fear
well what there's a giant bureaucracy of
fear yeah so what he implemented with
the great terror is that's in the in the
30s in the late 30s it was it was it's
throughout the 30s but yeah like it
starts in the um mid to late 30s
basically you know communism is based on
the common good and the public good and
anything private which was Bourgeois was
a problem when they were started you
know when the revolution came the
October Revolution they wanted to
recreate Society entirely and that
included like okay let's make it so
um uh uh everyone eats in like
cafeterias so they're eating by
themselves let's design buildings so
everyone has to share bathrooms like
their whole plan was to have eliminate
any kind of concept of privacy at all
they also had this bizarre kind of
radical idea of uh like attacking shame
so many of these you know before the
1917 people were also very involved like
free love uh because the idea of like
having this private bond between your
husband and your wife was also Bourgeois
and old-fashioned and you know we're the
Society of the future that changed
relatively quickly but they were talking
about things like raising kids
communally uh and and so on and so forth
so for Stalin if you and I are friends
we have a bond that's a threat to him
the family's a threat the any kind of
organization is a threat because it's a
power center that is uh not between a
relationship between you and him now you
have relationship with somebody else so
he systemically
went through that whole society and you
know it became you there's certain
things that became a crime then it
became a crime to be a spouse of the
enemy of the people now right away eyes
a child become an orphan because my dad
was the name of the people my mom is
married to none of the people
now I don't have parents they get
arrested or executed or whatever but now
I know where to go but I can't go to my
friend's house because their family
doesn't want to take in a child of the
enemy of the people
um you had this culture where everyone
was very much encouraged to turn people
in and if you turn if you're arrested
you know and tortured you're like okay
who are your accomplices and now you
just gotta name names people you knew
and then it becomes this whole chain and
it's like how am I going to protest my
innocence if Lex just said you know I uh
worked with Michael and we were working
with trotskits and we were plotting to
overthrow Stalin let's testify to this
he signed a confession what am I
supposed to do now right so it worked
its way in a most viral fashion through
the whole society there was this amazing
moment where these poor people peasants
because obviously the powerless are
often going to be caught in the web
they're going to jail for being
trotskyites and they had to ask
themselves what's a tractorist like they
didn't even know who Trotsky was uh and
the thing other thing is ethnicity was a
problem right if you were an ethnicity
you have more power with other members
of that ethnicity than you have with
this kind of broader Soviet culture so
he would just Deport entire populations
from their ancestral lands to other
parts a to spread the population around
but also to break that link between the
peoples and their lands there was this
1937 nkvd order against Polish people
where it's just like if you had come
from Poland or had uh just this whole
list and basically people were being
arrested because they had uh polish last
names and I think it was a million
people were killed like some
astronomical number
um so there was this anything that was a
bond was a threat to him and it went
systemically so after he had all these
kind of executions of people who were
like Lenin's people the old Bolsheviks
then he went after he started arresting
the secret police you know he arrested
all the cops he arrested all the judges
and all these prisoners got to see the
judges who yelled at them for being
counter-revolutionaries and spies now
they were in the jails if you were a
foreigner if there was a huge push from
the Soviet Union toward African
Americans right because they're like
look you're living in a racist country
here we have no
um
uh racial inequality come come live here
A bunch of them went and they were all
vanished you know anyone who knew
information about the outside world if
you're a foreigner
um uh Andre uh Babel I forget his first
name he had a French writer he was
friends with he was arrested in shock
because he's a spy because you're
friends with Melrose and that means if
you know a foreigner you're a spy
speaking Esperanto became a crime having
a pen pal literally anything that was
some kind of chain between yourself and
someone else was a threat and was
grounds for arrest it was uh the
Russians would joke
about how relieved they would be if
someone knocked on your door in the
middle of the night to tell your house
was on fire because it wasn't the nkvd
coming to arrest you and of course most
of the accusations probably were
completely false so not only could you
not do all of those things
you
were also a victim of just being late to
work became a felony and also not doing
your job became a felony because now
you're taking the food or product away
from the people and you're supposed to
be there working for the people there's
this one story which you know I I was
doing the audiobook and this is like I
still try and get through without crying
this was 1920. they were a bunch of kids
in Moscow who were pickpockets aged
between ages 11 and 15. they rounded
them up and they're like all right point
out your accomplices and they would take
them in the trams and you have to point
out people then they would take them
back to the this the seller beat the
crap out of these children and then they
take them out again and if they didn't
point out to anybody they'd beat them
they're like all right so they just
start pointing at random yeah and the
thing that was really sick about this
story if that wasn't sick enough is that
the screams that the other criminals the
adult hardened criminals had to hear
from these children as they realized
they were being taken back to the to the
seller it was just horrifying
and they so they tortured people they
tortured confessions out of people yes
at scale oh yeah
and the dark aspect of this is it's all
it's like this weird it's it's a
bureaucracy of torture yes so like it's
not like there's
what is it the torturer is afraid of
like does it so that he doesn't become
the prisoner right because then it's
like oh you couldn't get a confession
out of him are you an enemy of the
people now as well and the thing that
was even crazier is that a lot of these
interrogators were frustrated because
they're like look we both know you're
innocent just sign this confession and
make my life easier they knew it was
crap Stalin joked about Stalin joked
about this this is one of his little
jokes there was a kid uh who was
arrested and he was said oh it was
forced to say you wrote Eugene o'negan
which is a play he goes that play was by
Pushkin and they tortured him and they
tortured him tortured him and then his
parents are walking down the street and
they run into a secret police and they
go congratulations and they go for what
you go your son wrote Eugenia Negan like
he admitted to it last night like it's
just like they could get you to say
anything and what else was really really
sick which they understood is it they
lower the death penalty for kids I think
either 14 or 12 if I remember the top of
my head and what Stalin's head of the
secret police did is when you were
interrogating someone they would you
either had to have some of your family
member of that family members
possessions on the desk or a copy of the
decree that's saying you know that that
they can go after your family and the
amount of people who would confess to
anything when they saw their family was
in danger and they knew this wasn't a
bluff uh uh was astronomical and then it
becomes a chain because if you confess
and I have your confession how hard is
it to get your neighbor